groupe l'est républicain la parole est à
monsieur yves fromion oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre au terme d'une mission
d'information sur la mise en oeuvre par
l'union européenne du dispositif sofia
contre l'activité des réseaux de traite
des êtres humains à partir des côtes
libyennes vers l'europe
je souhaite appeler votre attention sur
le caractère singulier puis par cette
opération à laquelle la france participe
le dispositif sofia mobilise depuis
juillet 2015 des moyens militaires
maritimes et aériens de plusieurs états
européens
il a pour mission d'intercepter dans sa
phase actuelle hors des eaux
territoriales libyennes
les embarcations utilisées par les
organisations criminelles qui exportent
vers l'europe
les migrants illégaux originaires des
états subsahariens
si l'on ne déplore plus de pertes de
vies humaines en mer c'est parce que les
trafiquants conduisent leur embarcation
surchargée de migrants en libye des eaux
territoriales libyennes et en limite de
carburant là ils actionnent par
téléphone satellite
l'intervention des secours en mer c'est
à dire en fait celle des navires de
l'opération sofia qui prennent en charge
les migrants les trafiquants n'ont plus
qu'à empocher leurs bénéfices
quatre cent mille euros pour un bateau
de pêche et près de cent mille euros
pour un pneumatique l'union européenne
tend donc à se muer on associer d'un
trafic de migrants clandestins pour le
plus grand bénéfice de ses organisateurs
les responsables de sofia estime entre
500 mille et un million le nombre de
migrants en attente en libye et le
chiffre d'affaires du trafic s'élève
annuellement
toujours selon sophia à quatre milliards
et demi d'euros
une telle manne ne peut laisser
indifférent d'âge qui étend son emprise
sur la côte libyenne concernés par ce
trafic
monsieur le premier ministre qu'entend
faire votre gouvernement pour redonner
du sens à l'intervention européenne
avant que le trafic de migrants illégaux
ne reprenne avec la fin de l'hiver et
que des ch n'en prenne le contrôle et
les profits merci monsieur le début des
premiers la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de la défense monsieur jean
yves le drian
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
yves fromion vous vous préoccupez
avec raison des trafiquants méditerranée
il y a eu en 2015 plus de cent cinquante
trois mille migrants qui sont arrivés
sur les côtes italiennes et 90% d'entre
eux provenaient de libye à la suite de
ce constat l'union européenne a décidé
vous l'avez rappelé au mois d'avril 2015
de la mise en oeuvre d'une opération
elle l'a fait rapidement une opération
qui s'appelle le 9 mai de sofia cette
opération vise à empêcher les trafics
d'êtres humains depuis la libye et c'est
d'autant plus nécessaire maintenant que
des ch
depuis cette date occupent une partie du
territoire libyen
il y a trois phases à cette opération la
première phase c'était une phase de
collection de renseignement de fusion
des renseignements
la france y contribuer comme vous le
savez nous sommes rentrés maintenant
dans la deuxième phase qui consiste à
permettre des arraisonnements et des
fouilles de navires en haute mer
mais ça n'a pas de sens si nous pouvions
passer rapidement la troisième phase qui
permettrait l'interpellation à la fois
dans les eaux territoriales mais aussi
sur le littoral libyen la france y
contribuera y contribuer et contribuera
par des moyens aériens et perdre mise à
disposition d'une frégate mais il faut
au préalable que nous soyons garantie
par le droit international et que nous
soyons appelés soit par le gouvernement
libyen soit par le conseil de sécurité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutenons avec beaucoup de force
ça a été fait encore hier soir à venise
dans la rencontre entre le présent
reynésiens le président hollande pour
que ce gouvernement d'union nationale
puisse avoir lieu le plus vite possible
afin que nous puissions très rapidement
passer à la phase iii que vous souhaitez
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur laurent gang